let's say you just had a big browse
someone close to you they behaved
terribly maybe broke something and said
something hideous to you it's so
tempting to give up on them and just
hate them but there's another way here's
a big idea people are almost never
simply bad what they are far more often
is scared when they behave in really
horrible ways it tends to be because
they're extremely anxious for some
reason or another though their behavior
can seem strong no one who actually felt
strong would be or are see like that
the mature response shouldn't therefore
be to increased tension and flare up in
return but strive to see all you've got
in front of you is someone who can't
cope we are so alive the idea that is
patronizing to think of people as
younger than they are we forget that is
also at times the greatest privilege to
look beyond someone's adult self in
order to engage with and forgive the
anxious or disappointed viewers or
inarticulate child with them there's
another thing to bear in mind when all
you can see is persons weak points weak
points are always linked to strong
claims and vice-versa so for example the
strength of thoroughness is always going
to bring with in other contexts the
weakness of peasantry creative
brilliance might well be inseparable
from logistical unreliability people who
are fantastic leaders at work are likely
to be seriously difficult around
domestic chores the reason for keeping
this in mind is that we often encounter
people with weaknesses at moments when
we're in danger of losing sight of their
strengths at certain points all it seems
we're bumping into all the weaknesses we
wonder how do I end up in this
relationship or hanging out with this
person during tough times we only see
the flaws we are failing to step back in
up and asked a really vital question not
just what are these people's weaknesses
but what are the strengths of which
these annoying traits are the
unfortunate shadow sides everyone is
going to have the weaknesses of their
strengths forgiving people must mean
doing everything we can to keep their
strengths in view at moments where their
weaknesses are only too painfully
apparent if you like our films take a
look at our shop the School of Life comm
forward slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you